let's run this clip of Kevin Costner
because was very surprising to me I hate
to be one of those guys who ever latches
on to a conservative to a celebrity and
says he's a conservative but I think
you'll like what Kevin Costner had to
say on CNN about Ferguson in about race
relations in America fun dip roll clip I
got there I mean I I grew up in a place
called Compton when I say grew up that's
a loose term I was there for the first
eight years of my life so my extended
family my immediate family I we I was
very conscious of these words and I
don't ever remember them being said in
anger I don't ever remember them being
said but it doesn't mean they weren't
arrogant it doesn't mean they weren't
callous they weren't you know they
weren't ignorant if you will people's
feelings and so I saw it I used those
words
you know you've used that you said the
n-word sure and other multiple times and
when you have said anytime someone wants
to shut a conversation down you just
invoke race it's not the only way you do
it but you know when you want to shut a
conversation down you also can walk away
whatever happened in Ferguson so I think
there's so much going on there that
people will miss when he says when Kevin
Costner says sure I've used the n-word
many times in my life and it was when I
was playing with other black athletes
and maybe a majority of Americans have
never said it what he's saying is screw
you what he's saying is screw you for
trying to judge me on having ever used
one word because every single person in
this country at some point with the
exception of and I mean single digit
numbers has said the n-word everyone
from my generation anytime I sing along
to hip-hop radio which by the way
listened to a lot I know it surprises
people Kanye I do not look like a
hip-hop fan I don't I don't look like a
hip-hop fan you look like a Maple Leafs
fan Kanye's college dropout is one of my
favorite albums weird science is another
band that really I love Kid Cudi I love
hip-hop okay so to give you an idea the
deposition with Paula Deen remember
that oh yeah yeah well she was a baker
or whatever yeah yeah checkbook chubby
Baker looked like Ursula from Little
Mermaid that one she does she does she
was asked have you ever used the N word
that was that was the really big
question and she said yes and there were
other things that went on but she said
yes okay fun dip I want you to ask me
the steven crowder if I've ever used the
n-word steven crowder
have you ever used the n-word every
single time I sing along to college drop
out
Kanye's arguably best album every single
time if I'm in my car
I don't self self-censor if I'm in my
car singing along to a hip hop artist
because I know somewhere down the line
someone can accuse me of being a racist
fund it be honest at some point in your
life you've said that word at least once
I'm Pat Martin's son aren't I
okay but the point that Kevin Costner is
making is you can't judge someone by one
word without any kind of context anyone
in this country who wants to crucify
someone for having by the way if you go
out there and you actually use the
n-word in its proper racist context kind
of like Joe Biden did with Shylock's and
the Jews I about fainted when I heard
that he didn't even pause he just kept
going right on through like it was just
part of the everyday vernacular for Joe
Biden I think it is I think it is I
don't I I shouldn't say I don't doubt I
wouldn't doubt Joe Biden being an actual
anti-semite
but if you use the n-word in its proper
racist context yeah that's a terrible
thing it's a word that shouldn't be used
right I think that remembering the early
70s where I first heard it most commonly
used was in the the little it was almost
like a nursery rhyme the kids would run
around the neighborhood Daniel Boone was
a man he was a big man but the bear was
bigger and so forth so he ran like up a
tree
yeah and that I had no idea at the time
what it even meant what it was all I
knew it was in that little song yeah I'm
like what is that thing that's not a
thing that's a person and I'm like oh
right let me tell you this I don't know
how much time we have until the break
but we got a few minutes okay we got two
minutes yeah by the way everyone can see
you so these signals are no longer no
longer covert so keep them clean you
know keep them clean
don't keep them it's the internet no one
everybody okay
I remember when I heard the n-word
actually used in a racist way so I'm not
talking about someone's you know you
know I ain't she ain't messing with no
broke broke I'm not talking about
singing along to some song talking about
a guy using it where he was at a Bob
Evans I was at a Bob Evans at Lynchburg
Virginia and he sat down and he said you
know these filthy n-word and I remember
my heart about stop I couldn't believe
that I had heard someone used that in
that way and it made me realize just how
rare it is it made me realize just how
rare actual hardcore racism is we'll
talk about it after the break ladder
with Crowder